(angry crowd shouting)
(jazz music)
(intense music)
- Help, help me.
- Do you have an appointment?
- No, it's an emergency.
Okay, I just returned from space
and some alien, some thing,
put this monster inside me!
(man grunting)
And it's clawing out of my body.
I need you to get it out of me!
(intense music stops)
- Here's a pamphlet which
reviews your options.
- Fuck options, okay?
Here, I have insurance.
- I'm sorry, the state
does not allow us
to accept insurance.
We wouldn't want to infringe
on anyone's religious freedom.
(grunts)
- I'll pay in cash, I'll
sign whatever you want, okay?
Just tear this out of me!
(screams)
(intense music)
- Brad, studies
show that the life
growing inside you
now, at 20 weeks,
has the ability to feel pain.
Have you considered adoption?
- Listen, this thing
was put inside me
against my will.
- Well, the law
treats you the same.
Have you considered
the life choices
that you made that put
you in this position?
- Ah.
- Brad?
(heart rate monitor beeping)
(dramatic music)
- Alright.
We got it.
- Ah, oh my.
Thank God.
(laughs)
- We got the sonogram.
Take a look.
See the state law requires
us to make you stare at that,
before we can conduct
the procedure.
- No, it's still inside me!
- Wow, listen to that
heartbeat go, it's a miracle.
- Fine, fine, I
want the procedure!
- Huh.
72 hour waiting period, not
including weekends and holidays,
just to give ya some
time to think it over.
- Oh!
Fuck man, why can't you let me
make my own decisions
about my fucking body?
- Sorry.
State law.
I'm gonna see you next Tuesday.
Hey Tammy, we still
on for drinks?
(crowd shouting)
- Oh, fuck this.
Fuck man.
(intense orchestral)
(Brad screaming)
(squealing)
(crowd screams)
Get this fucking thing outta me!
(creature squeals)
(woman screams)
(crowd screaming)
(creature squealing)
(man screams)
(creature squeals)
- Once that sucker
hits the ground,
my Second Amendment rights trump
that whole pro-life thing!
God bless America!
(gun fire)
(theatrical music)